because i'd been on
a flattened my back for so long i had no
neck muscles
so i had to have a brace on and a high
wheelchair with a neck
cushioning at the back
when they hoisted me into the chair
i caught a glimpse of myself in the
mirror and i just burst out crying
[Music]
myself and my sister was attending
friend's wedding
in the evening driving back
i was a passenger in the car and
we had a car accident which resulted in
me being paralyzed from the shoulders
down
obviously i don't remember anything
about the accident
but initially after the accident
i was fighting for my life
my heart stopped on a couple of
occasions
and i was put into an induced coma
my body was
fighting with a severity of injuries as
well as a spinal cord injury and i was
touching over quite some time
i know at the scene of the accident i
had to be resuscitated by the emergency
services
and also when i got to any i had to be
resuscitated again
um do you remember being rushed to a e
in the ambulance
no why it's so bizarre though because
what i do remember is like i'm not sure
whether it's
me being
conscious unconscious or
where my mind has
i don't know it's where my heart stopped
my brain has gone off in a different way
because what i remember is not actually
what happened
so
at that point um
i thought after the accident
we drove home and
went back to my parents house and my mum
and dad was there but obviously this
didn't happen so
that was in my mind
and then it
flashed to a different part where i was
at an airplane and i've been put into
the cargo with the luggage
and
i just remember it being so bright and
really really cold
and then my brother and my fiance andy
was on the plane and we was all going
back to australia and
everyone was really happy
but then it changed and
i was then in this
complete darkness in this huge open
space
and i was sitting on a chair
like stuck but stuck to a wall
and it was just empty and silent
and then i hear the door go behind me
and it was my brother and andy
and they're so angry
and i can hear them talking and they're
saying
i can't believe she didn't come through
that's it we're done we wipe our hands
with her you know my brother said to
andy you need to forget about her now
you need to wipe your hand so that's it
we're done with her we're just gonna
leave her just leave her
i remember just sitting in the chair
and then i heard these voices
and i looked down
and i could see
i could see a light from a door like a
back entrance to a club
and i have no idea why
this person was there i i just can't
work it out but
it was snoop dogg
and he had
his entourage of people with him
and they was looking to kill me but i
remember the fear and i was so scared
i tried not to make a sound i didn't
want to breathe and i think you know
please don't look up please don't look
up and then my chair
slowly started peeling away from the
wall like it was stuck with velcro
and it was peeling more and more and i
was thinking oh my god please move i
don't want them to i don't want my chair
to fall and then be there and find me
as it came away from the wall then i
woke up
because a lot of a lot of people have
asked me did you see the light at the
end of the tunnel i was like no i didn't
i did there was no tunnel and people say
oh did you see any loved ones and i was
like no just snoop dogg really
um i don't know how long after
the dreams or however i would explain it
but when i actually woke up
i was
distraught because i thought that my
family and andy had left me
it was so weird and bizarre i thought
that i was in a psychiatric ward
obviously i was still on traction so i
was lying flat my back and i could see
it when i opened my eyes i could see the
tubes coming from my throat
and i wasn't quite sure what was going
on
and i was
i was feeling really sad and
just low at that point because i thought
that my family and andy had left me and
i was on my own and i didn't quite
understand what was going on and then my
mum and dad walk around the corner
oh and i can't tell you
how happy
and the relief i felt when i saw them
because honestly i thought that they
left me
and when my mum came walking up to the
bed i just burst out crying i couldn't
explain to her about my dreams because i
couldn't speak
and it was really difficult because
for me this is the first time i had no
voice
and she can understand what i was trying
to say
so
it was quite it was a very very tough
moment
could you just explain how you were told
once you were stable that you might
never be able to walk again
to be honest i actually
it probably took a lot longer for me
because i didn't believe it
like when i had been admitted to
sheffield's spinal unit they said to me
um
you you're going to be here for a long
time like you're probably going to be
here for about six to seven months and i
was thinking well they they don't know
what they're talking about i've got a
hen dude to go to next week i'll be out
they can tell me that i'm i break my
neck and i am paralyzed but they don't
want to give me the wrong prognosis by
saying you will never walk again because
they don't know that no one can actually
take us so many people
every
spinal injury is different
and you don't know the extent of your
damage until the swelling and stuff had
gone down so um
when i actually sunk in telling me i was
paralysed
yeah i think i had some pretty damn dark
days
at the start of it
definitely whilst i was in sheffield in
my house in the spinal unit i didn't see
any of my friends i refused to i didn't
want anyone to see me like that
three of the months i spent
lying flat on my back with traction on
my head and bolts attached to it
and weights so they held my neck down
so that my vertebrae didn't fuse
together
and then
i had to go through a stage where i had
to gradually sit up in bed so i sat up
for like 10 degrees then 20 degrees then
30 degrees and
i knew that i was
obviously going to have to be in a
wheelchair but
the realization of it
well that hit me like a ton of bricks
and they tried to
i don't know how they tried to make me
feel better by bringing me
a nice new wheelchair but
it was awful it was a one of the
a wheelchair was really high back
because i'd been on
um i flattened my back for so long i had
no neck muscles so i had to have a brace
on and a high wheelchair with a neck
cushioning at the back
so when they hoisted me into the chair
i caught a glimpse of myself in the
mirror and i just burst out crying
because i think that was the realization
is
this is what i'm going to be like now
this is what i'm going to have to use
so leaving there and going back into the
real world where my old life was
that was that was tough
to face the world
my same life
but a different me
i
i found it devastating i i did struggle
to start with i
i didn't want to go out i didn't want
people to see me in my wheelchair i
didn't want to see my friends
i didn't want to do anything i just
wanted i just wanted to stay in my
bubble
when people see you in a wheelchair they
think
i can't walk well i can't walk but it's
when you've got high level spinal cord
injury there's so much more to my injury
it's not that i just can't walk
it's
from the level of my injury you lose
sensation
you lose
the like the feeling of temperature i
can't feel temperature below my injury
so when i have a shower i can only feel
the heat to my shoulders when i have a
bath i can i can't feel the temperature
until i get in and feel it on my
shoulders
and i can't
most people high level spinal cord
injury don't feel sensation so
you can't feel touch or anything but if
you do it's like muffled you lose
sensation you lose the control of your
bladder you lose control of your bowels
and the most
hardest thing for me was my you lose
independent you have to rely on people
24 hours a day
so
you can't be spontaneous or anything
like that anymore you know you have to
rely on other people all the time and
that is pretty hard
i was always a party oh you know love
life
was always like the social butterfly of
the social life so for me
next time i'm to see my friends being in
a wheelchair
i just didn't want it
so what gave you hope for the future
one day and he was sitting beside me and
he said i've got an idea i think we're
going to set up a charity
we wanted to do it
to help me to explore different rehab
and different stuff out there would help
my journey and see what was available at
the time
so at that time when we
set about setting it up i don't know if
i realized how
how big it would actually become or what
it whether it wouldn't you know
become anything at the time
so
it's quite crazy now looking back and to
where the charity is today
it
we have a scholarship program where it
allows us to sponsor people to access
specialist physiotherapy
um
and the people that come to us for our
help they don't want pt and they don't
want you to feel sorry from they just
want to make progress and that's what
our scholarship program does it helps
you make progress
it's so slow in the spinal world
like a small thing
to others is a huge thing to me
i just don't want to settle i just want
to keep pushing myself i want to keep
bettering myself i want to keep making
smaller gains
but it's the little things in the
meantime you know i'm just going to keep
on working harder and i'm just making
progress so
now
i can manage to sit in a chair like this
and not only that i can propel myself i
can push myself around
i can
feed myself i can brush my teeth i can
do my own makeup
um there's so many
so much stuff that i have done now
because of physiotherapy and because of
rehab and i just want i want to give the
opportunity to others i want other
people to benefit from it as well and i
know they can
he obviously looked at my arm and said
to me we can make you about this size
the penis i was like whatever you know i
mean yeah that's that's you leave that
to him i don't i never i've been i could
have said to him about a ten inch one
you know what i mean
but you just you know i mean you're just
grateful you're getting that opportunity
you know i mean